weird wow okay vadim yeah i think they
really did it hey guys it's max we just
got in the second generation of
amazon echo buds and believe it or not
these have some very unique
features that i haven't seen in other
headphones that do compete
with the airpod pros so we are gonna see
which one of these
you should buy should you spend extra
money on the airpods or go for these
less expensive options and essentially
that it says it's made for iphone and
ipad and it
works with android so they're definitely
targeting ios
users now let's go ahead and pull this
thing out of the box
and when i saw the pictures it looked
very similar to the airpod pro case
you guys can see it's a little bit
shorter now but the design is almost a
copy
it's not as white though it's almost
like a gray color instead of white
all right let's get this thing open whoa
we lost it
i actually kind of like that the case
has this matte texture i feel like it's
not going to get as scratched up
like the airpods and the new air tags
and it also has a flat bottom so if you
want to just set it down like this
you can and instead of having it lay
flat like this but of course as you guys
can probably tell
it is definitely thicker than the
airpods pro and it's also a little bit
longer as well so it's not going to be
as
convenient in your pocket you will
notice it more so and even though the
case is larger it actually has less
rated battery life
the buds on both are rated for roughly
about five hours
but the total battery life rating is
about 15 hours for the second gen
um amazon echo buds compared to over 24
hours for the airpods pro
of course we have usb type c for
charging and if you want to spend 20
dollars more
you can get wireless charging as well
and on the inside we have a cable to
charge them up
and then a fit kit to be able to
you know make sure that these fit
properly inside your ear canal which is
very important
for the active noise cancellation and to
get a good base response
we also have these wing tips that you
can attach to get a better seal inside
your ear especially if you're going to
be active
now what i'm most excited about testing
is not only the active noise
cancellation which i have to say
was quite terrible in the original
version we actually didn't even put out
a review
but the new event feature that only the
airpods pro
have built into them which really helps
with that sealed
design so now let's go ahead and open
this up and as you guys can see these
buds
are fairly large they are quite a bit
larger than the airpods
pro and even though this does look quite
large amazon said that they made this
about 20 or 25
smaller so the older ones were huge and
now
let's go ahead and get this set up for
pairing you have to have the alexa app
downloaded and in theory
bam there you go you have these opened
up and close in
automatically finds it it took i don't
know a minute minute and a half just to
show up on the list
and we are connected we have a couple
tips here i'm going to skip through just
so we can test these out
and let's put them in for the first time
all right i wonder if active noise
cancellation is on
or if it's off having a hard time
telling they definitely block out a lot
of sound
and to be completely honest i don't know
if i can tell a difference as far as the
vent feature with the airpod pros
literally you put them in you feel that
pressure and all of a sudden like a
second later
it like disappears you can really tell
that it's working
whereas with these ones
i don't know is that just a gimmick is
something actually working
and now let's go ahead and test out the
active noise cancellation
let me go on and looks like it is
already turned on
so it's enabled out of the gate and i
can still hear my voice
pretty dang well but that ac vent noise
definitely
is mostly gone or all the way down let
me try to take a listen
that mostly gone let's pop these in
weird wow okay vadim
yeah i think they really did it really
well that noise cancellation
is definitely better on the echo buds
i still hear some of the vent and i
still hear my voice the higher parts of
my voice kind of like the samsung's but
they definitely get rid of more
low end noise than the air pods pro
i gotta say good job amazon these
actually work
good for noise cancellation where the
previous ones were terrible
and now what i'm curious about this is
where all the headphone makers
really struggle and that is the pass
through
or the ambient mode or whatever you want
to call it so let's go ahead i'm going
to be talking i'll hit this button
all right let's see how this sounds how
do i sound
you actually sound pretty dang good
really i sound weird
i sound really weird it's weird i
haven't heard this before
almost like lisby it's really really
weird
now that vent sounds very natural but i
just have a lot of background noise
let's go ahead and switch here
i have to say i love the controls on
these you just press and hold
yeah okay the ambient mode or the it's
way way better transparency mode
sounds awesome and way more natural here
and let's go to active noise
cancellation
and now i feel like i want these in as
far as blocking out that sound we're
actually going to go to the on an
airplane a couple days
i'm probably going to take these with me
because that active noise cancellation
is
a lot better now there's a few more
special features that are very unique
with the 2nd gen
echo buzz which i'll cover in just a bit
but right now i want to get into our
sound quality comparison
we're going to listen to a few songs
that i've tested in the past so i know
kind of what to look for
and we'll see how these compare let's go
ahead and get started with
the air pods pro
[Music]
all right well that was very interesting
these things are tuned completely
differently the airpods pro
we have a lot of high end and then good
mid and
pretty loud mids i guess and the bass is
good it's not overpowering but it's
decent
where these are very very base heavy out
of the get-go you still have the highs
mids are a little bit lacking at least
in this song and the bass is just
low and powerful and strong which
sounded fantastic and i think it might
work really well for this
next song
[Music]
all right wow actually these are a lot
better than i
expected i thought you know they might
be good for the price they might sound
decent
they sound a lot better especially in
this test i don't know if it's just
because it's a little more simple
we have more separation between the bass
and the mids and the highs
but it sounded fairly well balanced the
high sounded sharper than they did in
the last track
and the stereo kind of effect in that
that song
also sounded quite good for this one i
really have
no complaints i guess the only one is a
couple times i tried turning it up a
little bit louder and i'm somebody that
likes to listen to music
very loudly too loud honestly and the
airpods pro
do get louder but other than that i'm
quite surprised at the sound quality for
the money
but with that said for this next song
which is a rock track
things get very difficult there's a lot
going on and this is where most
headphones
really struggle
[Music]
all right wow that was actually pretty
enjoyable i don't know if my face could
say anything
the only thing i really wish was maybe a
little bit more high end where these
have a lot of high end
but man that low end bass and when those
drums are banging
and even the mids sounded surprisingly
good i honestly thought
this song is where these were going to
fall apart and the separation between
the different frequencies
would just get all muddied up which is
typical with rock music but they
actually did
a pretty pretty good job can i imagine
something yeah
dude those echo bugs are like extremely
loud to me like
are they i can literally hear the lyrics
no joke how are these how are the
airport frozen i just hear like a little
bit
but i can't make out the words but you
can make out the words with these for
real
really from here that's interesting
because for me
these are actually quieter when i'm
listening to them i want it to be a
little bit louder
and they feel super sealed in where
these ones they feel
they don't my ears don't feel like
they're plugged up whereas with these
they feel like they're plugged up just
like with the
the galaxy buds the only thing i guess
would make sense if they're like more
like open back
maybe that's what they mean about the
vented design because
apple actually made a big deal about
this and you could tell you put it in
it's plugged just like these
and also that pressure goes away these
are plugged from the very beginning and
then that pressure
doesn't go anywhere it stays plugged so
maybe that's their version of
vented is open back or like hey let's
get all the sound out of there for your
neighbors to hear
oh that has been so that's a really good
point if you care about only you being
able to hear a music
you might not want to get these don't
get them
and now let's compare the next thing
that is very important for these kind of
wireless earbuds
and that is the microphone quality i
have both
connected to my phone and let's go ahead
and take a listen this is the microphone
quality
using apple's airpods pro in a fairly
quiet environment with some ac noise in
the background
and this is a microphone quality using
the brand new amazon
echo buds second generation in a fairly
quiet
environment that does have some ac noise
go ahead and let me know which one
sounded better to you down in the
comments section below i want to hear
your guys's
opinions and the next thing i want to
cover is just the differences
in the capability i said that there's a
couple other things that these can do
of course we already saw that equalizer
we have some different options
you can customize what the controls do
so you're just tapping on the surface
for that
and then there's something that is very
interesting here
you can go back and there is a workout
mode where these
buds will actually track your miles
calories
your pace things like that now i'm
honestly a little bit skeptical about
that but i haven't tried it
just seems weird to have an earbud that
can track that
and realistically how accurate is that
going to be
of course you're not going to get that
with the airpods pro
so that might be a feature that is worth
using you know apple
of course wants you to buy an apple
watch for a lot more money
if you want to you know track those kind
of things and that's something i'm gonna
have to test out
in the future and as far as prices the
airpods come in at 250 bucks
compared to 140 if you get the wireless
charging case
of course we have a link right now in
the video description where you can pick
these up for under 200
sometimes 190 and the echo buds will end
up going on sale these always do so you
guys can check out the prices at the
time when you're watching this video
but overall these are less expensive and
i was really surprised in multiple areas
these smoked the previous first
generation air
echo buds those didn't sound good the
active noise cancellation was not good
they were really large the case was
large
these are a lot better and i was really
surprised that the active noise
cancellation is actually
better than the air pods pro and
with that now when i was listing that
rock track i definitely preferred
listening
with the echo buds the more classical
modern twist on classical
that sounded equally good on both i did
like the lower end
and the first edm song with vocals
sounded better on the airpods pro but
overall for the price these performed
much better than i expected so if you're
somebody that wants the
amazon alexa assistant or if you want to
integrate or you want those
um the health features the tracking
features or just to get a lower price
than airpods these definitely are a
compelling option but you guys let me
know
your thoughts down in that comment
section below this has been max click
that circle above if you guys want to
subscribe to see more videos like this
one then to help us reach
1 million subscribers before the end of
the year we would greatly appreciate it
and i will see you in the next video
you